андрей тестування на 2 чаї на приймальню
вид а ти по навантажила на
прем'єр-міністра України
рада вас тут бачать пани прем'єри з ваш
porsche та візи до берліну на посадила ви
уряду even пропав на душі складні часто
було їздить кноссе з проблемою brexit'у
що ви думаєте про це рівнями пошиття за
вірність та прем'єр-міністрами називається
в Європі самі мені меч і але до наших
стратегічних партнерів а україна ви
значилося вишнях я розумію сів за раз
божко божко і щасливо Європа мистецтві
і в давнину бика пари кінні там ще
політичні лідери європейського союзу
знають святовит неправильному режимі для с
найближчій галузі європейського союзу
Україна
baci мій шлях європейському союзі ми
продовжуємо у складаних
адже шлях такий мене нашої на за
важливості та
руку до європейської операції у котел
чого україни члени зникла
бажання про ігнат ishida europe
мистецтву юзу та на увазі на всі типи
9-ки може здатися csproj ним хаосом
Україна мою воду про асоціацію з
європейським союзом і справді не українців
особливо його після революції гімнастика
повернулася на українському майдані люди
засвітилася свої обожнювання шити
в рясний проводити демократичні
державі
і побачити свої мої будні в європейському
союзі цьому а ми зараз інтенсивно
займаємося внутрішніми реформами перед
творінням і те тільки щоб ефективно
подала ти корупції сторони ти я систему
правосуддя в нашій державі vitodito
економічні зрощення у нас я багата
задач таки нам потрібного вирішу ось з
цих повстаннях сир і нам навіть
вдалося роботи закриваючи за Петренко ними
чини прийшли від душі непростими вузькими
моїй агресії
російської федерації сьогодні та
фактично на нашій території знаходиться
весь до
російської федерації харчування бойовики
я хочу ще розповісти і про тещу ми
будемо і вдома салати
успіх українців заслуговує на складні
шляху в результаті ми будемо у матінки в
ніч перед вами сировина не завдання ви
найму луки голова уряду в історії України
16 український прем'єр ви прийшли на кшталт
саду здували добру репутацію після more
slowly знайти та успішно про водяну вам та
модернізації місця онлайн на
національному рівні стоять найсерйозніший
ви ікла викажи тисячу груди бас куртки
виводжу рівний пріоритет стійкі
результати а нас правдина потрібно
роботи багата оператори та за крима
я домовлюся у нас є три фундаментальні
ворогу
з російські танки російська агресія
батьки корупція та популізм популізму ки та
надеру їм нашій державі та самоцвіти
лікаря може забрати у нас знайдуть не хочу
заправлені тисячу я прийшов вночі садом
і загартував владу для того, щоб буде
кошики для своєї держави я хотів би
запускати що успіх рожевих українців
виштовхує distant вже багата система
за 20 травня там 5 руки в авку кинулась
all ці зрадники ми проводимо уми
розгойдав і судів, і формам витворив і все
Інституті типу ікла не за раз на
боротьбу з корупцією і він уже сьогодні
вдома будувати я уві сні я his neck рокки
ціни закладені в інституті кіра ніші на вигляд
найму хл та взуті у дамках бутікової
влада ями ланцюга три моєму ми проводимо ряд
структурних реформ
ці реформи будуть даватися і позитивні
результат треба на системному рівні
менше ти у бутиках олігархи у дикій
корупції на життя а просте крижані ці
наше завдання в чому у завдання я їду ж
напали клювання спину скомандую на голову
виду коаліції
для нас і поважав іван і просто by matt і
посади для склав його заміни ти наш
україна мета столичні шанси типів саме
для нашого покоління попрямуємо до was
like міліцію
парний гройсман хоботок щось поважаю вас і
протеже президента порошенка думати як
ти з тоді ще скрипкового синю з
коштують що президента Петро йому
олігархічні партії
отрута ви думаєте ланцюги дріго я вашу
політичну позицію у замітці я їв мани
і своя історія я печу і сказав і просто
ще був мером ми висимо rocky fry відповім
obara вся а путін проти віце-прем'єром
по тепловій верховній раді та за раз
прем'єр-міністром я лечу по юсб устілки
закладеним бити своїх класних після div
та intercept держави там у все in cinema
і жирного значення я поважаю за раз у
україні
цей момент коли і президент і парламент
і уряд мати ніби і динаміка кеес поїдом
агентському з успішним для того що
максимально ефективно проводять та
реформі
мого брата кров африці ж забув і
знайшли фокус їх решти двох уроків від
рибалка підпишіть ось і реформи треба
відро живуть і економічне заростання
хочеш сказати ще але все начебто
повз чому ж позитивний простим
стан економіки magic 2 висотка ввп
нам надавати нормальний клімат для
то загальні інвестиції проходи в Україні
вчора я можу стригтися німецькими бізнесами
ківі здача та
а поки що не ситуації в Україні ціна з
мало що війна подачу роботу цьому душа
увійшла його
щоб ми не гоївся ідеалом принципів і
своїм полем дам to die
не буде журналу складності на вигляд кого
ви кіль таразе загадав і російську
адже агресію і протікання буваєте на
сході україни римську млинець ваші
матчів у вас викликаного чує і росію
вісь ухилиться їх взаємних замовлень
робіть до всіх ти світу, а зараз
залишається російської агресії ас
навчальний вихід не тільки для України, а й
ви книг для всього цивілізованого світу
і обожнюючі на сході країни сьогодні і
постійний і внутрішній конфлікт
сонячної агресії Російської Федерації
до абсолютно підвищуємо ажурного права та
україна та жертвуєте та агресії all
видатковому кордоні
я за сьогодні демократичних європейських
тінистою ми не можемо моду пускати і того
щоб 20 вашій столиці прогадала з
іншим шлях шляхом кордону
сучасні держави щодо турів я оберу
влади виберу кінець до народу на
європейську інтер інтеграцію за годину
революційності туди навіть багата
вистраждала йому дуже багато підлітків
витрат на 6 віч та знаки та боролися за
свободу і ги боролася за те, щоб
як частини та європейської ради цьому
за раз потреба щоб вас вигляд
огурцова ну та розуміє агресору
сервісі не пройди повз нього повернуть їзда
по воді до мирного права ми миємо у
росії мої ви швидко своєї скроні своїх
бойовики з території України ми хочемо
над інтервалом цитата вулиці українці
сьогодні ніяких стояти в полоні
російських віскі з і вікі-віки та росії
Петро і ми цьому нашому жив його завдання
його всіх а свиту
щоб ми виріжте роздобувши зі світу на
континенті і тут
навіть важливу роль світлових років ірисок
вона хочу колись когось не мечами
федеральному канцлеру
за дуже читку пит ринку самих
демократичних цінностей у солі та
Євросоюз продовжу ксантиппа ти руси і на
6 місяців алекс рада не самого е100
вчитися з у парочки
0 в санкції шкодити знайти льке руссіано
євросоюзу стане ваша позиція
чи санктис продовжать і а санкції були в
дані
я поки що раніше затягну агресор поттера і
міжнародне право та розв'язавши скроню
виді на території суверенної держави та
бувають сьогодні ми їх спідера громадян
це було поки що раніше санкції можна
надати перешкода ти обох з менше ось
ці якісь цикли агресор вином і со
своїх плані плані настає від рівня
європейських цінностей демократії та
свободи вільно вибору мають держав
тугим вузлом замкнули на ти б знає я
думаю ще рости так так росії полежав
там ще б вас на живіт і все
демократичні держави і примушу ти
smooth це їх особливо його через російську
пропаганду
від проблем річки я сьогодні на сході
європейського союзу на складі України та
темні можна допустити випробування нашої
владні bus пкц харчування bespoke всіх
crying абу ми когось йому агресора у ми
а його держави і з чоловіком за вожатими
тварина права обидва ви на кліп це не я
хто наступна жертва у нас в історії
нашою була молдова була грузія за раз я
україна та навчальний вихід для всіх та для
всього європейського союзу почет у кістки
п'яні люди на сході України навіщо я
себе пивну світові та культурно та
економічно по в'язаних з друзів та душу
коротко за прикладом і ви за розбір чи не
не кусаємо петренко вивчи q це мабуть
чини стравами в жодному разі не загубилася
в україні та дружин їх ти скіф
клоччя дена квітів років набивалося українці
україні ніколи не буду внутрішнього
конфлікту миколи та
цю ж важливо вам затягнув результат
був 14 ротик билося там ще
красивий розрубала віроломні сторони не на
території суверенної держави анексію
чи мису свисток дав і в прямому
ефірі та коли український крим був у
курортом Давид спочивав і народу сьогодні
українські крим анексований та
військову базу та до 100 нових запитів до
всього світу там і дуже важливо щоб ми
зближалася вірність та позиції
не мічені тут я абсолютно не пакетну
з приводу демократії пав року суверенних
держав і до картону та мети
фундаментальні права на будинок тварини
права і уважно тут стояти душі
principal націй позиціям і ви чого йому
петренко не мінчин і ми нічого йому
лідерство за крима і в нормандському
форматі з гори protege по всьому світу
діяльності за keyword оборот з місія
прем'єр-міністра володимира грузії і ту
ж вам дяку і за інтерв'ю дойче велле
tiger